top three things that are going to
happen in 2016 I'll go first because
I've just you guys think about it cuz
I've been throwing you a [ __ ]
curveball so okay top three cool things
are going to happen this year okay
virtual reality I think a lot of people
are going to I think it's going to be
it's going to be probably the virtuality
is going to be popular okay you got the
people who buy it I don't know how much
more of this kind of cost hopefully it
comes out and the vibe is going to cost
a fortune and probably know what's going
by they've had a couple of real bad
hardware fails steams will not so sure
about that one and so that's what I'm
going to say number two I think no man's
sky is going to come out and I think
there's going to be a little bit of a
backlash over what exactly that game is
the scope of this the like I think the
perception of that is like reversed to
rocket League I think nobody knows every
just way too much I've been anticipation
about it and it's gonna swing the other
way but I do think it's going to be a
great game from what I've seen and the
little I've played and I'm talking to us
I think it's going to be a good game on
its own terms but I think there is going
to be a little bit of a backlash better
and three I bet the divisions gonna be
[ __ ] they had a that was one of my like
my first one I'd take your like thing
and I and I really really like the look
of that game but I'm kind of worried
that it's going to be a weird
multiplayer game and I don't think
Ubisoft it ever made it could not have
they ever medical multiplayer like as
ice cream on spare I don't never liked
what you think rainbow six each said OCT
okay yeah when they put all the round
bass guitar I'm not sure I don't know I
feel bad cuz i'm always down on yourself
like this i hope that now I I wanted to
make a new assassin's creed with to grow
home stuff they did go home was so good
yeah go home was brilliant so I don't
worry I'm gonna save it they're also
negative though I don't think I don't
think they will be good either I think
overwatch gonna be huge I think
overwatch gonna be huge that's that's my
voice it's just taking everything man is
you're a sorry sight and he's me I'm
really all right Mike you go sorry i
didn't know i forgot that i don't steal
your stuff Zelda's gonna be Wii U and X
on both okay and it's they're gonna show
it to us this year okay when X is
to come out this year though no no I'm
just saying they're gonna say coming to
wii u 0 + NX yeah and your enzyme we run
that a type we're gonna say um Oh at
least at least that's happening that we
think is gonna yeah okay okay well
that's I'm not asking you to [ __ ]
tell me like a list of celebrities are
gonna die like you can go softball on
this is what if you want um I'd say
there's gonna be in the next five months
we'll hear about two more Triple A games
at getting pushed to 2017 okay and
that's kind of an easy one but i like it
whatever fine i'll try to have at least
one of these follow through and what
else we'll hear about the 2017
assassin's creed they just announced
that they're not gonna have like a major
assassin's creed this year right which
maybe they just want to you know it's
like it's like you're playing it rocket
League and you want to go out on a win
maybe they just said yeah cynic it was
good let's take it over well yeah get
that grow home stuff in there man yeah
we'll hear about it and it'll be set in
alum India 11th century didn't you see
that Egypt at that room or no the rumor
it's an immediate we're talking with
Sasson sorry yeah yeah the room where is
it where's I know egypt egypt egypt yeah
yeah yeah all right wait we're talking
about sesame right yeah rumors of yes I
think 11 centuries way off it'll be a BC
like it'll be like 6th century I mean
eatable him packing OG Egypt yeah back
with Ramses and boys would you say like
six thousand bits yeah like that I mean
like what was it I think of 6th century
BC was when Egypt was as height yeah but
the like honk don't call me a nasty
that's the problem wasn't because he
says heist unlike isn't that it's like a
game Friday space terrain climbing tall
buildings and the only one that's gonna
be as the pyramids and everything else
is gonna be like two stories high I
don't know I guess so could be i was
gonna be really weird they're gonna have
to figure out how to climb they just
figured out how to fall down buildings
gracefully now you're gonna try to like
go up slopes and then you get the top is
just another slope on either side it's
all slope man it's a uh it's not smooth
no no find em hotel and they got that
way forget to get his armor and then you
go in the pyramid and it's
[ __ ] Stargate and then Richard Dean
Anderson sitting there with Teal'c and
he's like let's [ __ ] go kill some
grow old and then ran freighter come
through a time portal with pistols just
oh right here and then suddenly you're
in the seaquest dsv room with the guy in
the dolphin that's got the headset and
they're talking at each other a 90s
television is back and he tells us the
price for sony VR that's it yeah perfect
alright that's a good shoes top that man
it's probably gonna happen what you
think is gonna happen i think ah geez
there's that okay I'm gonna I'm just
gonna go opposite of you guys I think
the divisions gonna turn out better than
you think okay only because our our
expectations are so low that it can't
get any lower okay all right let's see I
think hmm one was positive that Sony vr
is gonna be cheaper than oculus just
because that's a thing they do now I
think they're just gonna be like five
hundred dollars oh my god 500 that's
what they do thank you to oculus um I
agree with that was a good one I'm so
funny that they can launch it at five
hundred dollars and get coffee or like
550 or 5 49 99 oh my god we can before
the game house all we're saying thank
you it turns out free copy of a
hundred-foot robot just took out that
xbox one controller that you're supposed
to get and that's why it's the same
price yeah forgot about that oh yeah you
get Lucky's tails Lucky's tale is not
really funny they should like to just
cool this should be like Palmer Luckey
sales Ness wapa at the character he's
just like floating through the air like
on a beach hey sorry last go ahead do
you have one I have a last one you know
make no claim is lost I think I think
that Final Fantasy 15 won't come out
this year okay even though i think they
seem like they're they got their [ __ ]
together but man was i burned by final
fantasy 13 yeah black playstation 3 for
that would I must say I'll say you're
right they did do the whole like we
taking your fears so can i request the
fourth from you all right what do you
think's happening with destiny this year
oh god that's did you don't move ECT I
think destiny to pause like very
possible I think not as many dlcs and I
think you're just going to see a lot of
events stuff with a lot of
microtransactions ok and I'm going to be
pretty sad if that is true but I kind of
in that way did you see the juve apart
no I would so I thought he might say
somebody expansion those curious did you
see halo 5 has one of the packs of items
you could buy is a hundred dollars real
world dollars really yes dude likes ice
what's in what's in it it's you know you
get those those packs with random items
in it they're like 10 tears now it goes
from all the way from one dollar for a
bronze pack to a hundred 434 gold packs
dude is there like some way we can like
figure out who the [ __ ] those people are
relying on dude that's what I want you
an episode of the pointers on yeah call
them no whales well yeah but where the
[ __ ] are they beached man it's like I
know I know at least of one whale but I
don't want to disclose his name but he
used to work here and he used to buy a
la liga legend stuff and other stuff
I've seen him I've seen him spend the
money I don't know what that is oh
they're out there yeah I'm always
there's always whales who are like
dropping money on our charity stuff I
was an or people who are super generous
so we got one on our what do we do for
extra life I got like 13 and a half
grand this year yep so somebody like be
dated the weekend through in 467 bucks
or something like that I just got an
email after the fact yeah cuz apparently
it's still open like it slope until
January something's mm-hmm we're gonna
do I get this automated email on my
iPhone and it's like yeah somebody just
donated four hundred something what the
[ __ ] so thanks hey yeah whoever that was
it's super charitable I wonder if there
was like some socks right off that was
coming in and they're like january first
doing it pic q1 convince a christmas
gifts they could have say that i've got
some cash but never want to go for
that's awesome oculus thanks so much and
we're gonna wrap this up yeah i'm
excited by the lobby situation you might
stick these bad boys on yeah you're
right we take that nice i might stick
these bad boys on the set we might do
something else I don't know we're gonna
do like a check-in video mean I need to
throw it out there to see like what
people want from a new show ya what we
currently have is this thing it's gonna
be on the set is going to be like a
tighter crew it's going to be for an
hour then we're gonna go play video
games on the stream for like 60 minutes
90 minutes to hours maybe and then the
friday show is like all
community-focused we might play games on
that as well more like take a bunch of
questions really just chew chew it out
and and we're going to turn them into
podcasts well this is definitely be a
podcast I don't know this we could
probably turn this
episode into might have to talk to the
guys in tact I might do that myself take
it up get that RSS feed going we might
do it on this if we don't do on this
episode we'll do it on the ones in
February and but yeah there's sets being
rebuilt so yeah we're doing it I'm super
excited 2016 2069 it's happening video
games are back or back with porn on them